so here's the news the trial of kyle
rittenhouse over the deadly wisconsin
shootings slated to begin november 1st
and last up to two weeks
so it we're we're getting there this is
an
update but there's a lot yeah
there's going to be riots
they're going to burn buildings down
kyle redknaus will get life in prison i
don't know for sure i don't know for
sure you said you were so confident when
you said it but uh uh it's going to
happen i don't know
i said kyle written house will get life
in prison i don't know for sure why do
you think that do you think that media
manipulation will push because regular
people
unfortunately too many of them are
cowards
that's like the nature of humanity even
even during even during the revolution a
large portion a large portion the
plurality the plebiscus they called the
revolutions like the the lesser informed
you know
animal bodies that kill the fields and
carry the rocks for you and that's why
you have a republican government
that's why democracy as defined by just
mob rule doesn't work and that's what we
have right now the public the republic
is gone so here's what's going to happen
they're going to do jury selection these
people are going to be there and they're
going to be like i don't want my house
to burn down
i don't care about this kid it's him or
me
see people used to have a sense of
community and scruples and they'd be
like i will not condemn this young man i
saw the evidence not anymore you may i
think it's possible we get a hung a hung
jury maybe one person just says no way
i'm not locking that kid up for this
that's self-defense but i think there's
a stronger possibility like we saw in
minneapolis come on you had that lady
who straight up said i couldn't go
through the riots i didn't want to go
through the riots again they had to
escort the jurors in the chauvin trial
into the building under armed guard with
like swat team rifles because of the
riots these people knew exactly what
they were doing said i don't care lock
them up i'm not taking this one totally
do you think the jurors in written house
are gonna are gonna are gonna disagree
they're gonna save their own butts does
that open that up to appeal i believe
uh there's a bunch of grounds for appeal
for shoving but what does it really do
grant him a new trial maybe i don't
think so i mean yeah we've had we've had
we had andrew bronck on we've had other
legal experts and they just said it's
not dude i watched rittenhouse as live
as you could possibly watch it without
being there
brandon g
and a few other guys they were on the
ground richie rich but like dude i
watched it as live as you could if
without being there
it seemed completely completely obvious
we've we've had i think
the entire uh
riot squad crew that was on the ground
yeah here at different times talking
about what happened one of the biggest
clips we've ever done was richie
mcginnis the journalist who actually
rendered aid to one of the guys who got
shot telling his story
i'm not gonna put words in his mouth but
i've i've heard witness testimony i've
watched all the footage
oh dude clearly self-defense but hold on
hold on it's not just about right now
check this out i got another story for
you you're gonna love this one uh uh i'm
gonna love it i bet elizabeth city
police arrest women accused of striking
two protesters with her car
she's being charged with assault with a
deadly weapon with the intent to kill
wow so uh she was
she was uh taken to
album album mary district jail with a 40
000 secured bond her first court
appearance is the 27th they say they
responded to a call around 6 45 p.m
this they she she struck me with her car
i watched the video she was going about
a mile or two miles an hour she was
driving through an intersection when the
black lives matter group started banging
on her car
she then slowly drove through and one of
the one of the black lives matter
protesters fell over
and injured her leg this woman was now
arrested and charged with felony assault
with a deadly weapon with the intent to
kill by using i'll read it two counts of
felony assault with a deadly weapon with
the intent to kill by the use of a motor
vehicle
one count of careless and reckless and
one count of unsafe movement remember
provo utah
provo utah was where somebody was
driving down the street and a group of
black lives matter extremists ran up and
one person pulled out a gun and shot the
driver
dude if a car is driving down the road
and you run towards its side towards its
side and throw yourself into the side of
the car hanging on it and fall down and
hurt yourself you can sue them no not
anymore the woke have taken over kyle
rittenhouse no no no as the person that
throws yourself into the car you can see
the driver of the car it used to be that
way but not if the person is a black
lives matter protester this woman has
felony charges too because he's saying
sue the driver i'm saying yeah you as
the pedestrian throw yourself into a
moving car from the side
you can sue the driver for hitting you
right right right right that's crazy to
me so
in dc and maybe it's like this in other
places too
people walk out into the street as an
active defiance and an expression of
power jaywalking right like they won't
go to the crosswalks they'll
deliberately walk very slowly across the
street strut and looking at you making
you stop your car with your eyes with
their eyes in the middle of the street
right and i don't like that very much so
one day i thought let me look up the law
on this right
if a pedestrian is in the middle of your
of your way to drive you are obligated
to avoid that pedestrian at all costs
that's the law
right if they jump out into the street
you you have to try to avoid them no
matter what even if they're wrong even
if they're committing a crime even if
it's a violation even if you're totally
right
that's the law i looked it up because i
wanted because i wanted to yeah no
because i wanted to know
it was this to me this is absurd use of
that perhaps that they attacked the car
yeah this woman was physically attacked
fortunately she was safe in her vehicle
in the video i've watched it
a mile an hour two miles just slowly
creeping forward
that's idling yeah yeah yeah not no i i
really doubt her for foot was on the gas
at all how slow she was going and they
were jumping up and down to banging on
the car as we've seen now she's got two
felony charges i warned this is going to
happen how many times have i said this i
love it there's like the left likes to
take select political moments like tim's
predictions are all wrong and it's like
i got a whole bunch and so and you know
it jack where it's like we were right
about this i said what two years ago
it's only a matter of time before the
police are like it's easier just to
arrest the victim than deal with a mob
so now you have a woman who is who is
attacked in her car fortunately safe
protected by her car who tried escaping
from a violent group of people banging
on her vehicle and the cops said the
i'll just arrest the driver
why am i going to support the cops
i'm sick of this you know people saying
defend the police not sorry i'm not
playing that game i'm not going to
defend anybody because this is what they
do they seize your guns they take away
your right to defend yourself they
arrest you in your own home and then you
get kyle renault's going to jail you get
the mccloskey's getting arrested and
they get their guns confiscated you get
the guys at a tillis gym the people who
are going in getting arrested by the
cops and all of these conservatives like
well it's not the cops fault whose fault
do you think it is
who literally went and arrested this
woman and put her in jail
the d.a no the d.a said in office having
no idea what's going on the cops showed
up and said we choose to imprison this
woman for trying to flee a violent mob
of extremists
keep supporting those people and then
when you're locked up next i won't
defend you i'll say what you you like it
if the cops come in if you if you are
walking down the street minding your own
business and blm comes and beats the
crap out of you and the cops arrest you
i'm gonna be like but you wanted that
you support the police what jurisdiction
was this with the car this is elizabeth
city north carolina where the rides are
exactly so the police have decided
because of the andrew brown shooting
they are going to arrest the victims of
violent crime because it is easier than
dealing with the mob by all means keep
back in the blue all day and night and
when you end up in jail because you were
beaten up by blm i'll say but you
support the police
aren't you happy that they've locked you
up in their facility it's what you
wanted isn't it oh i know they're
letting black lives matter go they're
letting them throw bricks through
windows and beat pedestrians and smash
windows
but you support the cops actually
people don't even know
right there i think uh there was some
research that just came out about
democrats awareness of antifa
none
no awareness oh oh this is this is
fantastic see i covered
a couple stories this morning and on one
of my earlier segments are you familiar
with ground news no so ground.news they
sponsored one of my my earlier segments
and it's really a great service this is
not a sponsor spot by the way but i did
do a promo spot forum before
they show you the amount of left-wing
and right-wing outlets reporting on the
story so you look at an antifa story and
what do you get you get a bunch of you
get every right wing outlet covering it
and then they'll say left wing and
they're back one and then far left zero
so of course the left and these these
progressives have no idea
i remember uh on the eve of the uh
inauguration and stuff uh or jan six
actually maybe like the week leading up
to that in dc they were boarding up uh
the buildings again and i went on
facebook to talk to a couple of my old
friends of something of course every
time
i tried to explain to them that the city
had been boarded up since may 27th and
they had no idea
people that live in the city that maybe
don't just come downtown that just go
suburb the suburb or the outer part of
the city or whatever they had no idea
that there had been riots all summer
long burning buildings multiple alarm
fires hundreds of assaults and felonies
and loot i was five feet away from
people looting
and they just have no
zero nada knowledge or understanding so
when i come on facebook and i'm like
actually guys it's because these blm
antifa folks have been writing all
summer they're like you're an idiot
you're an ass you're blah blah you're
the worst person in the whole world and
they unfriend me and they get all mad
because they challenge what they believe
to be their like perception of reality
this is the biggest problem
is is is how do we get people to let go
of their ego invested sense of reality
that they've actually fortified
with mainstream commercial news they
have no idea whether they're trusted or
not it just passively goes in their
brain they believe it i'm anti-racist i
don't know i'm not a race it's all a
perfect storm
of of trained ignorance
reliance on institutions that are no
longer trustworthy or valuable
and then an impossible task of
dislodging this fake reality out of
people's minds and when you try to you
look like the bad guy to them let me let
me show you uh this this from ground
news is really interesting
i pulled up the story about the woman in
elizabeth city hitting the protesters
with the car now
which
do you think it's left or right
reporting the story about the woman
hitting protesters it's definitely the
left and it's definitely framed as a
vehicular assault and you are correct
but it's not the far left it's just
center to
center left and left sources that are
reporting this uh the daily caller was
the only right-wing outlet to report
this which i find interesting because
typically the right does report on these
things but they frame it very
differently yeah so what happens
lefty people liberals will open the news
and go oh these people are hitting the
protesters these peaceful protesters are
being run over
so here's what i did i went i went to
ground news and i searched for antifa
surprise surprise uh all of their all of
the immediate links that pop up when you
search for anti-fun ground news right
wing source right wing source right wing
source right wing source 100 right wing
100 right wing 100 right wing i'm not
surprised
oh yeah antifa is not real everything's
normal this is why you see lefties and
progressives saying antifa is just an
idea it's why you get these politicians
who are completely dumbfounded and don't
understand what's going on
but you know
this is not a winning thing this is look
dudes people
i was doxed by a woman who claimed to be
antifa who had a flag and antifa flag on
her banner from twitter who led antifa
meetings who deliberately organized the
whole operation to docs and get me fired
and i explained this to people they're
like oh well i knew you were out of work
oh i knew you were having trouble oh but
antifa is just not no that nope just
keep it no no they put a gun to my head
they got me fired
yes
they ruined my life literally for a
short period of time destroyed my
reputation bro but you bruce lead it i
bruce you took their energy
which again if you turn it back on if
you do that then it also means you
didn't get canceled and it's not a real
thing and there was no negative side
effect for that but it's like these are
people
that have known me my whole life that
have been to my wedding
that know
my children
and yet i tell them like this is my
personal real-life experience
i was there i saw it they doxed me this
flag
doesn't read did you tell them with text
in person wow in person what was their
response this is just just it's like
opaque like like
film of confusion and disbelief
they can't process it because if i'm
right that means
everyone else is wrong and if everyone
else is wrong then maybe everything else
is wrong as well do you guys remember
that photo where all the people are
doing the roman salute the nazi salute
and one guy is just all frumpy like yeah
yeah so that's us we're the frumpy
people saying i will not salute
and those people are the ones doing the
red salute marching through the streets
they're literally doing what's called
the red salute google the red salute
the black lives matter symbol is the red
salute it is the communist symbol the
nazis may have been beaten but the
communists weren't yep
i had a conversation with my son just
the other night he's 14 years old and
he's feeling a lot of peer pressure
uh to do certain medical procedures that
we probably don't want to talk about
here
and i told him you know son it's lonely
doing the right thing
it's lonely standing up
and and when you're when you're 14
it's really hard to do that
especially when you're getting pressure
from your parents not me family
relatives cousins people in your
neighborhood your sports coaches your
teachers at school the parents of your
friends
very difficult to stand up and do the
right thing i i
i'm very proud of him he's told me
before about how during the in the
morning during the pledge of allegiance
everybody in class just talks and like
doesn't do it and doesn't pay attention
he stands up he says he's the only one
that stands up every day for it
and so i know it's inside of him but i
know that he's struggling right now
because it's really hard
it's really hard to stand up and do
what's right when everyone around you is
doing something wrong and thinks that
they're doing something right and
they're telling you that you're wrong
and that you're stupid that you're evil
and you're gonna die
you're gonna die if you don't do this
thing thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time